[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
uh how is morale in the PGA Tour Steve
Sands joins us now on loan from Golf
Channel he's there in Toronto the
Canadian open how is morale
oh you know it's been better Dan
um you know I I think that the farther
we get away Dan from Tuesday Morning the
more of an understanding the guys on the
PGA tour have of exactly what took place
perhaps the messaging wasn't exactly on
point on Tuesday morning and I think as
the details start to come out uh
privately with the guys and also
publicly over the next couple of weeks
and months I think that perhaps the
image or the framework of what we heard
on Tuesday will be a slightly different
than what we had an understanding of
around 9 9 30 in the morning on Tuesday
okay well give me a sense of what is
golf going to look like in a year from
now
yeah that's a tough one I think a year
from now Dan I think it's a little
different than say January of 25. I
think we're so late into the year that
the PGA Tour schedule and the designated
tournaments and the major championships
and the Ryder Cup coming up in September
and the way the DP World Tour has
conducted its business and some of the
guys over on that side who went to live
who decided to you know go away from the
DP World Tour and the same thing with
the PGA tour players I think things will
look relatively the same in 24 Dan but I
think in January of 25 and moving
forward I do not think that live will
exist in its current form and I think
the PGA Tour will be strengthened by
some of the other best players in the
world coming back uh paying a penalty a
fine uh suspension however that works
out
do you think Jay Monahan keeps his job
you know over the next couple of years
I think that it'll be a rocky road uh
for Jay I think once he fully explains
exactly what happened uh what took place
with the guys uh I think that he
certainly has a seat at the table on the
board uh I think that the players
certainly have a seat at the table
um on the board and I think that with
Jimmy Dunn with Ed Hurley uh with you
know Jay's Trust From The Players
previous to Tuesday you know you build
up a lot of equity Dan you know that and
I I think Jay has a chance to survive uh
for sure but I do think it's going to be
a rough ride for him is Greg Norman
going to be involved moving forward in
your thoughts I don't think I don't
think there's any way that we see Greg
Norman uh involved in this I I just
cannot
see anyway that Jay Monahan the PGA Tour
and all the things that have transpired
over the years we're going back three
decades Dan you know this with Greg
Norman fighting with the PGA Tour I
cannot see how Greg Norman has any type
of say in what takes place moving
forward but he's largely responsible for
golf being where it is today
he and Phil Mickelson uh may come out
smelling like roses uh in this now we
have to wait and see how it all plays
out Dan but for sure if this all comes
together and if the live guys who took
the money are able to come back however
they're able to come back to you whether
it's a big fine whether it's suspension
whether it's both uh whether they even
want to come back and play a PGA Tour
golf if that does come to fruition and
they can play in the major championships
and the President's Cup and the Ryder
Cup
for sure Greg Norman will somehow uh
come out of the smelling like a rose
which is pretty remarkable well it feels
like maybe as they move forward if it's
true that Greg Norman said we're not
doing away with the live format that
maybe there's more events where there's
teams that are playing in events but
it's still 54 holes and yeah I think I
don't I just don't know how that works
moving forward if they want to just save
face to say oh this is golf but louder
and you know come on over and realize
how much fun we're having here and you
need to have more fun on the PGA tour
Dan I don't I don't see any way that
underneath the PGA Tour umbrella I don't
see any way 54 holes shotgun start music
blaring guys in shorts is going to take
place they certainly will not happen
head to head against the PGA Tour events
which there are seemingly every week and
I'm talking beginning in 25 I think in
24 I think what Greg said uh yesterday
or the day before about things going to
be moving forward uh no change here I
think in 24 I think that it's kind of
late in the year for that to completely
blow up but I do think by in 25 there's
no way Dan you and I have known each
other forever uh and we also are massive
sports fans golf fans we understand the
inner workings of how the PGA tour works
it's a tradition based sport you're not
moving the rim up to 11 feet just
because these guys are are coming into
the NBA more athletic and bigger size I
mean that you're just not you're not
gonna do things in sports that are going
to completely alter the tradition of the
game and to me the PGA Tour you have to
have uh some of those traditions and I
just don't see how the live model will
exist here moving forward in a couple
years Steve Sands the play-by-play Voice
NBC Sports golf channel and he'll be uh
on the call with the Canadian open if
you could interview one person involved
in this today who would it be
oh man I would
can I give you a trifecta or no you
don't want season yet
by the way Dan does the Belmont even
matter anymore anyway so uh
I would say I would be interested in
interviewing Yasser
more than I would be interested in
interviewing Rory Jimmy Don Ned early or
J Monahan I would want to interview
Yasser if I was allowed to sit down for
15 minutes like you do all the time so
brilliantly and I would love to sit down
for 15 minutes with Yasser and kind of
get a an understanding of what they're
trying to do then what what are they
accomplishing I'm not a huge fan I I
watch a show all the time and I talk to
you and talk about blah blah but I don't
know where you're where you sit on the
phrase Sports washing I don't know where
you sit on that but I I want to know
what they're thinking I want to know
what their Avenue is into this sport
they've done it with Formula One band
they've done it with soccer they want to
make an Olympic push uh they clearly are
making a push into golfing and now have
I'd like to know what
the purpose of it all is and I would
love to interview Yasser I find him to
be a fascinating character uh in all of
this yeah I'm curious what the end game
is for them with their money and I'm
wondering if you know they wanted to get
the LPGA Tour as well and I think they I
think they want to get everything under
their umbrella as much as they can
um but are they but are they trying to
get the umbrella Dan or are they trying
to be a an investor in the sports and
all these other sports and all these
other businesses I mean I heard
yesterday that the the fun the pif fund
is worth 600 billion dollars a hundred
billion of that is allocated somewhere
somehow in business in America so it's
not like they're
the umbrella it seems like they're not
silent investors that's not the right
way to put it my business Acumen is not
high enough to speak on this but it
doesn't seem like they want to take over
the sport it seems to me that they want
to be involved in the sport say like
Dubai 35 years ago they built the golf
courses the tourism Abu Dhabi was the
money in the business of the UAE and
Dubai became the Vegas of the Middle
East and the world outside of Las Vegas
of having so much fun and golf and all
those kinds of things it feels to me
like Saudi Arabia and then the pif Fund
in particular I can't speak for Saudi
Arabia but it speak to pif that they
invest in things to get involved in it
not necessarily to take over the sport
but I could be wrong on that
The Bryson dechambeau interview oh man
you would think that they get talking
points right they they had somebody that
they hired to give them talking points
when they first went to live and people
are going to bring up 911. Jay Monahan
brought up 911 the 911 families you're
playing a golf tournament in the
backyard of 9 11. all of these things
and then Bryson dechambeau
like who do you think approved that and
said yeah go out there and talk at 20
years that's enough to get past 9 11.
come on now people make mistakes you
can't if you went to live for money go I
don't care good for you but don't tell
me that all of a sudden hey they made a
couple of mistakes and you had 13 people
involved with 911 from the Saudis and
let's move past that you know
that was cringe-worthy yeah it was a
tough one uh I mean you and I've been
doing this so long Dan you would like to
think that before you step into The Fray
there on CNN with Caitlin Collins
there's an incredibly accomplished
journalist who deals in things that are
way more important than Sports she
wasn't trying to Corner him she didn't
Ambush him she asked him fair questions
and he did not handle them very well
you'd like to think that hey talking
points Dan that's the first thing but
but B more importantly than
I really I'm not picking up Bryce and
per se this is anybody stay in your own
lane you know I know you are an
incredible golfer and you're a great
player but to try to articulate the
thoughts of what families from 9 11 who
have suffered so greatly over the course
of the last 22 years since 9 11 happened
to try to articulate that is just a
mistake on my part like I said Dan stay
in your own lane man what do you don't
go that path I just stick with hey I'm a
golfer and I I can't even fathom what
those people are thinking and move along
instead he doubled down he expounded on
his thoughts and ah oh man that was that
was a tough spot what does Rory McIlroy
do next
well I think Rory
probably
you know how when your kids are little
and they learn a valuable lesson man and
you say boy they're awfully young to
learn such a valuable lesson I think
Rory learned a valuable lesson as to
whose side who's on
who's transparent who's not can you be
transparent when you're making deals
like this Rory has a lot of faith and
trust in Jay Monahan and Jimmy Dunn
they're good friends and they're
partners of his
Rory is as you know Dan he's a well
thought out uh a bright young man who's
obviously a fabulous golfer I think he
would be best served then to and I'm not
his big brother I'm not his father uh I
had a nice conversation with him the
last couple of days uh here in Toronto
if I was giving him advice I would say
take a step back and just play golf and
and be with your family uh be involved
in tour issues if you choose to be uh
but don't do anything that you've been
doing the last 12 to 18 months Dan take
a half step back and don't be the face
and voice of things moving forward you
did what you thought was right at the
time uh and now here we are and I think
you ought to concentrate on just your
golf and your life have we heard from
tiger
we have it interestingly not publicly
um you know I think tiger is one of
those guys like Rory like a lot of a
bright people who are in the public eye
uh not that there are a lot of them but
the bright people who are in the public
idea and I think they take the measured
approach let's get all the details and
then I'll have something to say as
opposed to I'm not saying Bryson to
Shambo is not bright or Phil Mickelson
or Greg Norman but don't just spew on on
Twitter and go on shows that you
shouldn't be going on and speaking about
things you shouldn't be speaking about I
think tiger is waiting to see what the
details are that's one of the things I
found so interesting Dan about Tuesday
morning was that rarely do you see such
a huge announcement like this
and have the details only be half baked
you know this isn't fully cooked yet
nobody knows exactly what's going to
take place I think Tiger's waiting to
see what the details are before he then
offers up his opinion good to talk to
you have fun up there behave
all right Dan good to talk to you it's
the first time I've ever been on your
show we haven't talked about the all
lobby boy I'm I'm happy we've moved past
that you did a great job though in in
Sochi you were an unbelievable Lobby guy
like you were a one seed at the bar you
were you were incredible
yeah but I'm Purdue losing the you know
fairly Dickens
here's the deal Dan in order to be
recognized as an all Lobby Bar
participant one would first have to be
in the lobby to witness that so I think
it's a joint venture to use the PGA Tour
terms it's a joint venture between me
and you on the all Lobby team in Sochi
later we live in PGA Tour
me and you no no we're always we're
always on the same side okay we're on
PGA Tour side or we on live Liv's got
all the money well I'm on the PGA tour
side because I didn't take the money you
have 125 million not me I took the money
here you took the back yeah okay yeah
yeah uh hey good to talk to you again
all right thank you I'll talk to you as
soon as soon as you're down our way
we'll go out to dinner again okay that's
Steve Sands at the Canadian open